This episode was made possible by generous
supporters on Patreon
Hey Crazies.
In my last video, I explained how mass and
energy were the same thing
and that got a bunch of you wondering:
What the heck is energy?
I’ve said a lot about energy on this channel,
but it’s spread over multiple videos.
It’s time to put it all in one place.
Hmm, where do we start this?
Definitions?
We have to be careful though.
Physics tends to use a lot of ordinary words
in not so ordinary ways
and “Energy” is no exception.
There are a lot of ways we use this word in
the English language.
I feel the energy of the spirits.
Definitely not what we’re talking about.
Oh man, I am so out of energy.
Good example, but not really a definition.
I get energy for the power grid.
Again, good example, but not a definition.
A typical definition for physical energy is
the ability or capacity to do work,
but that just raises more questions.
What the heck is work?!
You don’t got to go to work work work work.
Ok, the point is we can’t understand energy
without understanding work.
We need both together.
But let’s make something clear.
Energy and work are just properties.
They’re numbers.
Objects and particles are physical things
that exist.
Objects and particles have properties, like
energy and work.
Work work work work.
Take a ball, for example.
We can label where it is by assigning a property called “position.”
We can label its motion by assigning a property called “velocity.”
An object can have motion and that motion is real,
but the velocity we assign to it is not.
It’s just a useful number.
Properties are useful because they measure
something we want to know.
All of these properties here, measure all
of these things here.
We need to figure out exactly what energy
and work are measuring.
Work is a little easier to understand, so
let’s try to figure that one out first.
Everybody’s working for the weekend!
A typical definition for work is that it’s
done on an object by a force,
as long as that force contributes in some
way to how the object moves.
Let’s say you wanted to do work on this
book.
All you’d have to do is push on it with
enough force to make it move.
That force times the book’s displacement
is the work done on the book.
We know a force measures the influence or interaction amount,
so it makes perfect sense that forces are involved in work.
The key here is this displacement.
In order for work to be done on the book,
it has to move from one place to another.
If the object doesn’t go anywhere, then
no work is done on it.
No matter how much it feels like work to you.
A working class hero is something to be!
Stuff has to happen for work to be done.
In fact, that tells us exactly what it is.
Work is the amount of stuff that has happened
or, if you’re making predictions,
the amount of stuff that will happen.
So what’s that make energy?
Well, let’s look back at the definition.
If energy is the ability or capacity to do
work
and work is the amount of stuff that has or
will happen,
then energy is the amount of stuff that could
potentially happen.
There is an upper limit to how much stuff
could happen
and that upper limit is measured as energy.
Thanks for liking and sharing this.
Wait a minute! What stuff?!
Do you think the crazies are going to be satisfied
with you just leaving it like that?!
OK, I guess you’re right.
OK, so there is a lot of stuff that could
happen:
Lifting, swimming, climbing, dancing, swinging,
waving, running, slithering,
doing other things,
boiling, electrifying, chemical reactions, nuclear explosions.
Let’s just say there are a lot of options.
Right, so how could all those things be the
same thing?!
They’re all examples of energy being used
to do work.
If you’re lifting a box, you’re turning chemical energy in your body
into gravitational nergy.
That change does work on the box, moving it
upward.
You didn’t use all the energy inside your
body to do that work.
Just a little bit.
All of the energy in your body is all the
stuff you could possibly do.
The work is what you actually do.
That box now has energy it can use to do stuff,
like fall down.
The gravitational energy is gradually turned
into kinetic energy on the way down.
That’s not even all the energy inside that box.
Sure, it has gravitational and kinetic energy,
but it also has thermal energy because it’s
not an absolute zero and a whole list of other energies
tied up in the material.
None of which are getting used to do work.
The only work done is the box falling.
That’s the stuff that’s happening.
So how do we measure these things, anyway?
Well, we don’t, at least not directly.
Unlike position or velocity, energy and work
are properties that are hidden from view.
We have to calculate their value by measuring
something else.
If it’s gravitational energy, we measure
a distance from some reference location,
usually the ground,
and calculate the energy using some equation.
Twice as high means twice the energy, meaning
it can do twice as much stuff.
If it’s kinetic energy, we calculate it with a measured speed.
Twice the speed means four times the energy,
or four times as much stuff.
There are equations for finding all types
of energy
and every single one adds to what an object could possibly do.
If you can change energy from one type to another
or move it from one object to another, you’re doing work.
Something will be happening.
Working in a coalmine, going down down.
There are a lot of different places we can
find energy,
so it helps to split them into categories.
We could take the list and organize it based
on where we find them,
but there’s something we can do that’s
a bit more useful.
All energies can be described by two generic
types:
Potential Energy, related to location, and
Kinetic Energy, related to motion.
That’s all there really is.
Remember, the purpose of energy is to show
us what could happen
and the only way things happen is if they
move from one place to another.
Location and motion pretty much cover that,
so can you label all of these
as potential and/or kinetic energy.
Nuclear energy is just the potential energy
of protons and neutrons.
Chemical energy is just the potential energy
in chemical bonds.
Thermal energy is wiggly kinetic energy plus
some material potential energy.
But don’t location and motion depend on
your point of view?
Yep, and that’s more evidence that energy
isn’t something tangible.
Energy is not a thing by itself.
It’s a property of things,
so there’s no reason in particular we’d
all have to agree on how much is there.
If location and motion are relative to the
observer,
then so are potential and kinetic energy.
There’s always some kind of reference point where you define zero.
For kinetic energy, it’s usually your own speed.
Two observers moving at different speeds aren’t going to agree on the motion of a third object,
so they’re not going to agree on its energy either.
That’s perfectly fine because energy isn’t a tangible thing.
It’s just a number.
A similar thing happens for potential energy.
For gravitational energy, the reference is
usually the ground,
but there’s nothing special about that choice.
You could move that reference around and it’s totally fine.
What matters is the difference in energy between two events across time.
That’s the work done.
That’s what’s actually happening.
She works hard for the money!
So what the heck is energy?!
Energy is amount of stuff that could happen.
But, in the end, all that really matters is
what does happen
and that takes work.
So, got any questions about energy?
Please ask in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
The featured comment comes from Dale Hildebrand who said:
The idea of relativistic mass can lead to false conclusions.
Well, yeah, sure it can.
I even said in the video that it can get really confusing.
But that doesn’t mean relativistic mass isn’t real.
It just means that it stopped being useful.
Anyway, thanks for watching!